joining me now is arkansas senator tom
cotton senator
um it's fair to say the honeymoon is
over uh
and old joe doesn't quite know how to
balance
all of these issues without either
not remembering or just downright lying
about them which is
what happened last night
well laura first i would congratulate
you on beating the cnn
presidential town hall in the time slot
but i know you don't really
view that programming as a worthy
adversary no i don't but
i gotta say i gotta say those clips that
you just played
um are not exactly the
man who would send xi jinping quaking in
his boots
when we try to stand up for americans
jobs in america's security and i got to
say that joe biden looks deeply confused
if he does not think that six trillion
dollars is going to add to even more
inflation
driving up the prices of everything from
groceries to gas
and also if he thinks that the rest of
the world thinks america is back
he is even more deeply confused because
joe biden is putting a kick me sign
on uncle sam's back to everyone all
around the world
now biden has another response senator
to the uh
soaring inflation that i think everyone
needs to hear tonight
if you're pumping all of this money into
the
economy couldn't that add to no look
here's the deal
moody's today when a wall street firm
not some liberal think tank
said if we pass the other two things i'm
trying to get done
we will in fact reduce inflation
reduce inflation reduce inflation
he says it three times and it comes true
senator
is that true especially given what
romney and company are planning to do
to give this big bipartisan sheen to
biden on this so-called infrastructure
bill
no laura joe biden again is deeply
confused if you think six trillion
dollars of spending is not going to
ignite even more inflation
remember that's just on the demand side
on the supply side joe biden is causing
inflation as well
they're giving out 300 weekly bonuses
still to keep people from going to work
they are sending out checks without any
connection to work
or having a breadwinner in a household
old style
cash welfare completely divorced from
work from work
so when you have all that money chasing
after goods that are hard to find
because we're paying people not to work
then yes we're going to have the
inflation we get now and more of it if
those bills pass
well senator what's happening with this
so-called infrastructure bipartisan
agreement i think is really shocking
nancy pelosi said she's not going to
push
forward on the infrastructure until the
senate agrees to the framework
for the 3.5 trillion spending so why
should these republicans have marched up
to capitol hill
essentially give them a huge win on this
uh bill when we have massive spending
that's going to be crammed through in a
reconciliation
leading to all these other economic
problems and a massive change the way we
live our lives here
why would republicans give them that why
well laura what nancy pelosi said today
is actually worse than you portrayed it
you said the budget framework now we
expect chuck schumer to bring that
budget forward in the senate in the next
month or so
but what nancy pelosi is saying is the
house wouldn't pass an infrastructure
bill
until the actual implementing spending
deal
is passed three and a half trillion
dollars of spending months and months
of work um so i got to say nancy pelosi
didn't do
any of the senators working on this
package any favors today when she said
that she was going to hold hostage any
bill that passes the senate
until the senate agrees to pass a bill
that includes three and a half trillion
dollars but other things
like we now know they're going to try to
sneak in amnesty for millions of illegal
aliens into that bill as well
i mean i guess that's another example of
what they call so-called soft
infrastructure
which again is just far left liberal
priorities
i mean these these so-called republicans
are getting played every minute
thank you senator good to see you and
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else